let's see what's going on with Donald
Trump so for those that missed this
Donald Trump was doing a press briefing
all of a sudden and this this kind of
freaks me out a little bit the Secret
Service whisper something Trump leans
over like what is it and they very
slowly go about it was a little
evacuated a little it wasn't like he was
rushed out so he wasn't uh under threat
it feels like duress yeah it was it
wasn't that he was like all right I'll
we'll go see what the situation is he
just kind of meandered out the room yep
that's it but the reporter is like
what's happening what's happening he
stopped talking mid-sentence and then
the I think the guys I can't remember
the guy's name who's the guy is it from
Fox John Roberts was that who was oh I
don't know yes yeah Trump's like you you
heard it right it sounded like gunshots
and he's like yes two gunshots and he's
like oh good job you did a you did a
fair reporter yeah I saw your report I
saw your report good job Trump was
really chill yeah he was like he was
just kind of like just chilling he
wasn't yelling at anybody but then he
went off on Obama you know he didn't he
didn't like go off on him but he was he
was simply he kept his chill the whole
time they kept asking him like so were
you rattled like when what happened he's
like there will be a report you know I
don't have all the information do I look
rattled look rattled to you well have
you have you ever seen the video of when
someone tried rushing his stage during a
rally and he like spins around really
fast and like holding on to the podium
oh I did see that yeah people see oh
there's something there people see what
they want to see man and the left was
like oh look he's freaking out and I'm
like somebody rushed the stage and his
first reaction was to spin and address
the threat he didn't run fall down yeah
like he spun around to see what it was
like
it's a good good reaction and then here
when you when you have a report of like
a shooting outside and the Secret
Service like we have to go he's like
okay yeah you're like very chill about
it I mean I gotta admit I'm kind of
worried look in in the same briefing
where he says what do you say probably
treason yeah because he's he's like
floated that you know the crime we call
the political crime of the century
that's what he said that it was the
political crime of the century of them
spying on him I mean they've caught them
red hat he said they caught we caught
them red-handed they were spying their
campaign was spying on my campaign and
uh that's the whole reason Nixon got uh
impeached the Watergate scandal yeah
Watergate is because he was spying on
the DNC so this is literally them spying
on Trump trying to get him not elected
to try to stop him at all costs
what does all costs mean who knows lying
lying I mean and throwing Flynn under
the bus any means necessary or at all
costs yeah this has me worried you know
I saw that I don't know if you guys saw
this it was a video of Bill Barr and he
came out to a bunch of protesters I
think it was a black back the blue kind
of scary and he was like shaking hands
and waving and I'm like taking pictures
yeah no yeah but to see the do you see
the the agents they were they were right
there yeah they were like Hawks looking
around
they were probably nervous Kennedy
Kennedy had Secret Service man but he
had the top down but it was it was also
a you know a parade you know they were
they knew the route I mean you know bar
was just driving he's like oh that's a
back the blue protest come on let's
Circle back to him you know that people
have tried in the past on Trump yeah
yeah man yeah we'll be careful with the
language that's why this is this is a
crazy story well wait four days was it
Ford Thursday he said I have Rich
enemies yep and they don't like what I'm
doing so you might not see me for a
couple days but now he's back nice back
at the at the White House for the Press
briefing and sure enough what happens
yep somebody we don't know what happened
yet yeah nobody knows Secret Service
we're like waiting for for information
guy gets shot apparently they say he was
uh the suspect was shot and taken to a
local hospital
I think that's the only thing we have as
of recording this video so maybe maybe
tomorrow or you know we'll have more
information on this but uh for those
that are watching live we have this
video you can see the Secret Service
came in whispered to Trump trump just
walks on out that it was very chill yeah
but that's probably the smartest thing
he can do I mean if he ran out people
would be freaking out get really crazy
but considering what he just said when
he went to Ohio
you know we got rich enemies yeah then
this happens there was that story I
don't know if you remember this wasn't
it like some dude showed up to one of
his rallies and then tried grabbing the
gun from a security guard or something
whoa what was that a couple years ago
man I have to look it up so here's a
here's an update from the U.S Secret
Service about what happened he's they
say update the investigation into the
officer involved shooting is ongoing a
male subject so we know it's a male of
the of a USS the U.S Secret Service
Officer were both transported to a local
hospital so oh maybe so the secret
service agent was uh is being
transported to the hospital also that's
new information to me actually also at
no time during this incident was the
White House complex breached or were any
protectees in danger so I I didn't know
that a secret service agent was actually
being uh sent to the hospital that's
from their Twitter account that's from
the official US Secrets what if somebody
man I don't want to speculate too much
yeah that's that's all we know so far
were you able to find that story yeah
from 2016 he was at a Las Vegas rally
yeah looks like he tried some dude tried
to grab a gun
yeah from one of the agents
yep for the specific purpose of stopping
Trump man so listen Trump does got a lot
of power from powerful enemies yeah I've
been I've been having conversations that
kind of freak me out because it's people
I never expected to hear from telling me
how much they love Trump I'm not
exaggerating I am not exaggerating man
but whenever I talk about this
invariably the left is like Tim's lying
and making these things up yeah what
they want me to do is force me to be
like here's the name of the person who
who hit me up and said yo they're you
know they're voting for Trump or
whatever right because they want to go
after their careers they want to
threaten them and there's a reason why
these people are scared to speak up
but I've had I I've had shocking
conversations man yeah to put it put it
mildly and you know what really did it
what the riots yeah no joke I'm not I'm
not surprised the Democrats have openly
said these aren't riots these are
peaceful protesters as people burn down
their cities and the Democrats are like
you know turning a blind eye or
supporting it or Worse supporting it you
know so we see that like wheeler was
walking around standing in front of the
courthouse and they attacked the
courthouse and he's like I see nothing
nothing's wrong here this is this is
what freaks me out and we'll definitely
come back to the right stuff later is
the idea of by any means necessary right
what have we seen over the past several
years with Trump first of all before he
even got elected yep they were saying
Russia
and and then Trump gets elected Russia
we get years of this very obviously fake
and now we're learning it's all nothing
and this is what what Trump was bringing
up with Obama when he said when he Daily
Mail says he accused Obama of treason
but I think you mentioned he said
probably he's here we go he says look
the Obama campaign spot on our campaign
and they've been caught all right now
let's see what happens to them but they
have been caught they have been caught
red-handed it's probably treason it's a
horrible thing that they did and it
probably never happened before at least
nobody got caught doing it but they but
they used they used the intelligence
agencies of our country to spawn my
campaign and they have been caught there
are a lot of people involved he said oh
and then he goes on to listing a lot of
those people which I noticed they didn't
uh actually list any of the names Joe
Biden's potential VP he was he was
dropping well that's what the original
question was about exactly so they the
reporter had asked you know what so what
about is it Susan Rice yeah Susan Rice
so what about Susan Rice that they're
claiming that they're gonna
she would basically wipe clear any of
this you know the allegations
allegations when we have actual proof
that this has happened and he's like you
know I don't know anything about that
specifically and then and then he goes
into that that's the beginning
everything they did to try and stop
Trump yep and has me worried about how
far whoever these you know I don't know
if it's Democrats or their their
corporate allies the people who stand to
lose money from these trade deals how
whatever the reason is we got you know
Adam Schiff for instance
he published private phone records of an
American journalist
and he won apparently won the court case
I guess Judicial Watch sued because like
wow yeah how can how can a U.S
government actor get private phone
records of somebody and publish it
they're trying to smear John Solomon
he's a journalist
we I everything they've done Ukraine
gate impeachment they've been desperate
to jam them up shut them down stop him
so when Trump comes out and says I got
enemies man yep he's got enemies
politically you know financially
ideologically well and the media has has
spun this whole
Trump orange man bad thing for years now
that TDs is a real thing so you get
deranged people with full-on TDS and
they're blaming Trump for things that
the Democrats are honestly more to blame
for the the official diagnosis is called
Trump anxiety syndrome oh is that it's
legit real yeah well I say legit real
but apparently there are some you know
uh psychiatrists uh diagnosing people
with Trump anxiety syndrome so it's Tas
yeah that's that's what they call it
right I believe so Trump anxiety
syndrome wow so colloquially you know
people call it Trump derangement
syndrome yeah yeah but derangement is
meant to be like a dig at them for being
like you know they're deranged whereas
I I I I I agree with you I agree with
you but a clinical diagnosis is going to
be like the specific underlying cause of
the anxiety
yeah man you know you know I saw a post
from a friend of mine and it said settle
for Biden and then it said it was a
picture it said Joe Biden and it was
like not gonna bring about any
Progressive policy and I said Trump evil
right I thought to myself the only
people who think Trump trump is evil are
the people who don't actually research
anything exactly because the I think the
most honest place a liberal would come
when it comes to an assessment of trump
is he's gross he cheat on his wife I
don't like his policy ideas I find him
disagreeable or unprofessional but evil
right you know what I mean it's not
normal to be fair you know it's
ridiculous I think where we are there's
a there's still a similar position we're
in because I look at Biden and I'm like
I don't know I kind of think Biden is
evil that's a good point I mean
videos of him sniffing kids and like not
letting them go like holding them and
being like a weird like and then talking
about kids on his lap and like just
weird creepy things that he says about
children it's disgusting beyond that I
would I would I would actually clarify
and say it's not so much that Biden
himself is but the Obama Administration
was definitely oh I'm saying it for sure
for sure that Biden is yeah definitely
the reason I bring it up is wrong with
him well evil though right so sure I
mean you but you look at his past
policies about you know basically being
for segregation and and the crime bill
that calling people animals that yeah
that can't be you know they can't come
back into society because they're just
animals and they need to be locked away
and it's just like those are his words
you see what hotel Jesus tweeted what do
you say he said the hate for Trump is so
real Biden can say anything about black
people and get away with it that's I
mean it's true absolutely I I saw that
and I was just like man that is it that
is the truest statement I've ever seen
he nailed it Joe Biden is you know
Donald Trump's really chilled out he is
you know I remember like one of the
things I personally didn't like was I
find it funny when he's when he when he
makes fun of Rosie O'Donnell and when he
says these things I do not consider it
presidential I agree but he doesn't he's
not he's been doing that because he's
becoming a president he didn't he wanted
to be president for a long time yeah and
then you know he when he finally became
president he was trying to do all these
things and he realized how to get the
changes that he wanted he needed to go
about them differently so now that the
president the Trump that we're seeing is
becoming president Trump so the next
four years you're going to see an even
cooler calculating person yeah he
doesn't drink he doesn't smoke he's got
a clear head you could use he's calm and
collected he knows what he's doing and
he spent you know not four years going
through the ropes of the legalities the
office of legal counsel and all that
stuff exactly do you know about that uh
that dude in California is a big
Democratic donor and they keep finding
dead overdose dudes at his house wow no
yeah you know what I'm talking about
right Buck I would say yeah yeah there's
creepy goings-on man over on over on
that that side and you know when I hear
about stories like that when I hear
about Biden's history but even outside
of these things it's like
the the Democratic the Obama
Administration did a bunch of really
really terrifying things and that's why
it's weird to me that progressives are
settling for Biden I don't I don't
believe it I really don't I couldn't
believe it either because I remember
during the Obama Administration all the
progressives look when the RNC happened
in 2016 there were there were very few
protesters if any yeah but the DNC had
thousands thousands that's the
definition of a of a progressive
uh I guess it I guess
man it's hard to clearly Define it's a
reference to getting rid of cultural
norms and advancing Society okay
progress progression it's typically
associated with a movement away from
tradition towards New Way new cultural
ideas and new ways of doing things okay
so there's there's a positive part about
it and a negative part about it well
it's neither okay I can see so uh in the
in the past the progressives were the
pro-eugenics party okay and they
abolished they abandoned that Principle
as part of you know whatever their
movement is so it changes that's why I
say it's hard to accurately Define and
then what does conservative even mean I
think it's interesting when I see people
like conservatives say liberalism is is
a mental disorder or that you know
liberalism is a problem and I'm like no
no no no no no Classical liberalism is
the foundation of this country yeah yeah
I get it though what liberal became as a
word you know as we Define it in this
country is something else agreed so I
look at you know we've got
it's kind of like a gradient between
regular Democrats default liberal types
all the way to the far left
and the biggest the biggest areas are we
have the far left that hates Joe Biden I
do not believe they will vote for him
but then you have these
pseudo-progressive Democrat types who
just wave the flag like they wave the
banner they have no idea what's going on
and they call Trump evil they don't do
any research and they're really hard to
talk to they just pass memes along like
this is this meme shows all of my hatred
in facts that I believe oh my favorite
are like I've been seeing it over and
over again why don't we just put
homeless people in in houses
why don't we just give people food it's
like that's a great question why don't
we where is it yeah where do they where
do they come from yeah to get it to you
when I try explaining to people like if
you put a homeless person in the house
then what do you do like there's a much
more comprehensive program has to go
into housing people who are unwell and
you know mentally ill or unable to work
or or you know refuse to they don't they
don't care to them the answer is as
simple as hit the button boom problem
solved scarcity isn't real they say I
kid you not so TDs is real a to EAS Tas
Trump anxiety syndrome I think Trump
anxiety yeah so so I want to go back to
this uh Trump being escorted off before
we move on yeah Robert said he heard Two
Shots yep so and now we'd found out from
the Secret Service that two people are
being rushed so maybe maybe the guy shot
at a secret service agent and they shot
back yup maybe he was I don't know man I
don't I don't want to speculate because
there's a lot I could say right well I
mean there's a little bit of speculation
that we have to do because we don't know
everything but we do know that you know
someone got shot and now we found out
that a secret service agent is also
heading to the hospital and we know
there was two shots that were heard
so it may have been so banging it
probably shot at each other both got hit
who knows how badly right now there's a
there's a Twitter uh Trend that said
interrupt Trump okay where the goal was
to interrupt his press briefing somehow
interesting and then all of a sudden
shooting outside the White House hmm
y'all that's crazy right yeah where'd
that where is that from I don't know
you're on Twitter right you can pull it
up yeah yeah uh in the trends hashtag
interrupt Trump was was check it out
yeah was was popping up quite a bit
I don't I don't know you know I I say I
don't know but I really what I really
want to say is I got a bunch of ideas
but I'm being very careful not to
speculate too much because we're dealing
with a very very serious matter about
the risk to the president yeah I'm
really worried for Bill Barr did you did
you see his interview with Mark Levin on
Fox News I did yeah the things he was
saying I'm like man I know
Trump said that he's seen the Durham
report so and he said it's breathtaking
so we know
I mean and and he he goes on to label
some of these people that he said were
probably committing treason
you know so and he lists a few a few
people like at least six six names
including Obamas and bidens and then he
goes on to a few others and it's just
like he kind of Giggles a little bit
when he says Comey because I think yeah
you should hear did you hear it the
little giggle in his voice he was like
hen Comey because because he's probably
yeah you're not a fan of that guy he's
probably the center of it all
man I I kind of been feeling like when
the mayor of La said he was going to
send utilities you know company to shut
off your power and water if you assemble
I'm like that's it there's no there's no
Constitution anymore for them no the
Democrats they don't know for anybody
they don't care for anybody you could be
a republican in LA and they could come
shut off your water and who's gonna the
cops were standing there with them there
that's a good point they're going to do
what he says that freaks me out man will
these cops just walk up and shut your
water you know not that cause themselves
at the utility company but are the cops
going to allow this violation of human
rights violation of the Constitution
apparently so they're breaking these
parties up look what they're doing in
Chicago the mayor while these riots are
going on she's been spending all her
time complaining about people having
parties on the beach and stuff yeah it's
like you're allowed to assemble period
end of story First Amendment says it who
are you to send in cops and who are
these cops to go out there and enforce
it speaking of that you see that video
from I think it's from Adelaide or
whatever Australia the cop choking the
woman or something dude Australia is
nuts well I guess it's Melbourne
Melbourne yeah they're they're really
cracking down there and it's it's I
don't know authoritarian crazy man so I
I want to just get back to this like
right I just checked out this interrupt
Trump there's a there's like a video of
of the officers like
collecting the person that got shot let
me see if I'm looking at it and they're
just kind of outside of the the White
House on the corner and they're just
they kind of zoom in there's a bunch of
cops around it it's like from the
interrupt Trump hashtag yeah yeah it's
pretty insane I cannot find it go down a
little further a little further huh
there it is here it is okay so it looks
like we got footage
this uh this you sure this is the right
one uh that's the one I'm looking at I
mean it looks like the White House is
behind it
so it's hard to really see what's going
on the police have blocked off the area
but they zoom and it looks like
someone's providing first aid can't
really see it too well but yeah
it's probably better we can't because
YouTube would nuke us if we actually
it's just people standing around YouTube
calm down yeah that's all it is I mean
literally just a little context yeah for
our story here wow crazy yeah and they
put hashtag Trump is racist in there
it's like dude dude you gotta you got
video footage of like an emergency
response for people being rushed to the
hospital chill out you know this got me
worried man well I guess I'm looking at
through these and it's about uh confront
stopping him from being able to lie to
the public
and it's like I've been listening to his
stuff and then I I cross-reference with
what's actually going on I follow the
news myself so I'm listening to him and
going yes this is correct information
and then I'm watching the news media
twist it and say that's fake here's the
fake stuff that we're talking about and
it's more of this fake stuff because I'm
watching I'm reading the actual bills
I'm seeing the actual stuff happening
with eyewitness reports you see what the
media did to me what oh yeah well I was
in here when you were having that stupid
conversation yeah yeah so I'll make this
I'll keep this quick because I don't
have anything pulled up but I tweeted
that Bill Clinton was in record was
recorded in Flight logs and now he's
been id'd uh um by a victim as being on
you know the island Epstein Island yep
and I said this is not it's it's not
it's you know there's no one cover it's
not a major headline story journalism
died a long time ago uh news
organizations are just political
advocacy groups
a fact Checker I saw it on Facebook and
rated it false
and now on Facebook this tweet of mine
appears with a flag that says false
information
when you go there the the article
actually confirms everything I said is
true fact Bill Clinton was in Flight
logs 26 times yeah fact there uh Roberts
or Virginia dufre Roberts in release
documents did say he was there and what
did they do they added something to my
tweet I didn't say that the flight logs
were to the island I never said that
nope the point I was making in my tweet
was that he was connected to this
individual right through flight logs and
now now he's been id'd as having been on
the island this should be a major story
he's a president former president of the
United States Bill Clinton yep so I
called the guy and he's like you got to
submit an appeal you got to go through a
process I'm like no no I'm not doing any
of that like he and I asked him I said
is Bill Clinton recorded in Flight logs
that's what I said he goes yes I said
okay
did a witness ID him in documents yes
okay
is is journalism being dead in opinion
yes is me saying news organizations are
political advocacy groups and opinion
thank you so you've confirmed that my
tweet is factually correct in every way
why would you put this label on it yeah
that's the game the game they play is if
you say something that goes against
their Orthodoxy they will add something
to it right now Adam is wearing a gray
beading a white shirt let's do a fact
check in the style of how Facebook plays
the game
claim Adam Crigler was seen wearing a
gray beanie and a white shirt
and he had a small little stain on the
side of his mouth
false not true then all at the bottom it
says well it is true that Adam Kluger
was wearing a gray beanie in a white
shirt no one ever said that he was
actually having a stain on his mouth
they add something that has nothing to
do with anything that way they can claim
it's false that's what they did do I
have a stand on no no I was making
something but that was the point I never
said in my tweet that the logs showed
him going to the island yeah I was
trying to make a point about the
connections and now we have the
documents released they added this they
put hoax alert was built was Bill
Clinton logged on on in a book flying to
Epstein I never said that so how now
Facebook is de-ranking the content as
fake news when it's real legit
information
I get these news organizations trying to
trying to knock me down that's that's
the danger of the game we're playing yep
thanks for checking out this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast we do the show
live Monday through Friday at 8pm if you
want to catch the full show tune in to
this channel subscribe hit the like
button or check us out on iTunes and
Spotify and we will soon have this
podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode